blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
all right i need your help figuring
something out is this
a political story or a mental health
story that i am going to be talking
about right now and what i mean
is a pro-trump attorney lynn wood
who was involved in trying to overturn
the 2020 election results he spoke at
some length at an event in south
carolina on tuesday
and claimed that donald trump is still
the president donald trump is still in
control of the
military could authorize a nuclear
first strike by the military if he
wanted to
so that's where the question comes from
is this a political story
or is it a mental health story and
lynnwood simply needs impatient
treatment i'm not
being facetious i'm not playing koi with
mental health it's just not clear to me
what kind of a story this is so let's
just jump into the video
donald j trump has never conceded
because he won the election so be cool
it's all gonna be good in time
donald j trump is still the guy the
military will call
for the code if they need a first strike
joe biden
so that's already like a treasure trove
of gold
uh if the military needed a first strike
they'd call
trump for the code and by that i assume
he means a nuclear first strike the
scenario that linwood is laying out is
the military wants to strike someone
with a nuke
they go to joe biden and say sir we need
the codes
and biden says no we're not launching a
nuke so the military says let's call
trump at mar-a-lago he'll give us the
code
sir give us the code biden won't here it
is have it
boom a nuke is launched it's a
delusional scenario i mean truly let's
watch a little bit more of this
[Music]
somebody do something well you got to
remember this man
because listen i think they're going to
fix this election in a month
right but we've gone right back into the
same swamp
and the same mess and nothing would have
really been fixed
so remember this isn't about trump and
this isn't about flesh this is about god
this is about powers and principalities
god's getting ready to clean up this
world
and he's got a lot of plenty of them to
do in america so
you don't want trump to come back yet
because
some things are going to have to happen
he's going to enjoy when
the bad stuff happened he goes whoa i
don't like that biden administration
it's not going to be on trump's watch
but trump is
watching so now he puts out this other
idea
we could have overturned the election
with the results in one month
but then if trump came back in it would
have been more swamped because we
haven't fixed the swamp yet this isn't
about trump it's about these other
things
so trump will come back in time when it
makes more
sense for donald trump to be back but
for now trump is watching
and he's ready to do the military strike
because he still controls the nuclear
codes
those are some big claims being made
and none of them have even the slightest
connection to reality
let's listen to the last bit here which
it might be the craziest part of all of
it
i believe my own personal belief is that
he signed the insurrection act
nobody knows he's not going to tell
anybody i think the military is prepared
to act if we have a foreign threat or an
internal threat that
can't be held by the police and the
national guard and we're going to allow
that to be what appears to be continuity
of government it's going to be painful
about some things where you're learning
about what you could have got if you've
really gotten by
because he's cleaning things up so
i know it's tough to hear lynn wood
because of all the constant coughing
in the room my guess is that's maybe a
not heavily vaccinated crowd
but he said there he thinks that trump
actually signed the insurrection act in
private
and the military knows that donald trump
still is actually in control of the
military
which is out of this world bonkers i
mean just
completely divorced from any even
possible reality
and seriously this stuff has an impact
it's not just linwood people believe
this stuff
there are right now or at least a couple
days ago there were people walking
around
filling plastic shopping bags with
liquid gasoline
and those some of those same people
refuse to take a vaccine that is safe
and can end the pandemic of course
there are people who hear this and they
believe it and they act accordingly
um and uh you know the
the incredible um kind of it's not
really a
it's a conflict i guess i would call it
is that on the one hand
if you ask these folks how do you feel
about what joe biden is doing while in
office they'll say it's terrible
joe biden is doing all of these horrible
things but then at the same time
some of them still believe that donald
trump is really in power
of pulling all the strings and
controlling everything so well so how is
joe biden even able to do anything if
donald trump is actually still in power
don't even try don't even try it will
merely be an exercise in frustration
and this is actually very interesting
news ex-white house
counsel lawyer don mcgann
will have to testify behind closed doors
about donald trump's efforts to obstruct
the russia investigation now again
i know that whenever this comes up some
some portion of the audience will say
david you've fallen for this conspiracy
or that conspiracy or whatever the case
may be i'm not falling for anything
i don't think this will lead to any
repercussions for donald trump trump is
out of office the ship has sailed the
russia probe was never going to
result in trump being charged or removed
or anything like that
but don mcgahn is a guy who as white
house counsel
was privy to all sorts of relevant
actions
uh by donald trump and who has been
ignoring
and avoiding congressional subpoenas for
a really long time uh
it has now been determined that he
indeed is going to have to testify um
don mcgahn will testify before the house
judiciary committee
yes behind closed doors about donald
trump's attempt to obstruct the russia
probe
the house and the justice department
have announced this in a court filing
wednesday night why a court filing if
it's a testimony
that will take place behind closed doors
for a political body because he had been
ignoring the subpoena
um the interview was going to happen
quote as soon as possible there will be
a transcript released so we will know
the substance
uh cnn reports that the committee
members who interview mcgann can ask him
about the incidents documented in the
mueller report of donald trump's
attempts to fire
robert mueller to block the russia
investigation
and about the accuracy of that
investigation
the justice department can assert
executive privilege
or mcgann can decline to answer on other
topics
that will prevent house democrats from
learning
uh details about other trump-era
scandals which is too bad
but this is still better than nothing
and this
is a major concession from the executive
branch because for years
the trump administration was trying to
block exactly this
from happening and uh this became
something that went into court uh
because of the degree to which don
mcgahn was just being obstinate on it
and uh we are now going to get at least
some information
so it's been a two-year standoff it went
to court it's now over
democrats wanted don mcgahn to testify
he's going to testify but it will be
behind closed doors
there will be a transcript and the
topics that are acceptable
for which he will be forced to answer
have been outlined and they are the
conclusions of the mueller investigation
trump trying to obstruct the
investigation and fire mueller
and the uh accuracy therein but beyond
that don mcgahn can say not going to
answer not going to answer my
expectation is democrats will try
on some of those other topics knowing
that don mcgahn is going to decline to
answer
merely to get that on the record
although in transcript form it's
definitely less interesting or dramatic
than in video form and i look forward to
reading very much about this if you um
are skeptical that it will lead to
anything
i'm right there with you i am not
reporting this to you as wow look at
this bombshell we're about to hear all
these unbelievable things from don
no no no i understand that that's not
going to be the case please don't come
back to me in six months and say but
david
uh you were saying that the don mcgahn
testimony was going to be
some kind of blockbuster of him no i'm
just curious to see what he says
it's a great thing that he wasn't able
to fully avoid this
it's been a two-year court battle and it
is ultimately going to be going to court
and that's a very
going to uh court decided he will have
to testify
uh and i look forward to seeing what he
says and how evasive he is
and we'll see what happens beyond that
uh monday memorial day
we will be doing a single day membership
special
just one day if you've been thinking
maybe i'll get a membership someday
if you've been thinking maybe i'll use
one of those coupon codes
monday memorial day is the day to do it
okay it will be a one-day membership
special
if you want to be notified just get on
my newsletter
you can do that at davidpakman.com
sign up for the newsletter monday
memorial day you'll get an email and it
will tell you
exactly how to take advantage of this
coupon code
as well as exactly what that coupon code
is all right let me know what stories
you're watching
find me on twitter at deepakman we have
a
it's just like a packed program today we
may
oftentimes after these shows are done we
just delete the files when we don't feel
very good about the show
a lot of deletions have taken place
we're keeping today's
show archive because it's bound to be a
very good one we'll be right back after
this
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important
core insights from each book so it's
perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
all right remember that the best way to
support the david pakman show continues
to be it hasn't changed
becoming a member at joinpackman.com
it's incredible how consistent that is
you can sign up if you want a coupon
code
using the code better21 or pay full
price which is still very very
reasonable
okay let's speak to some people we do
now
speak to folks through the david pakman
show discord which now has i don't know
12
13 14 000 people subscribed to it you
can find it
at davidpakman.com discord
let's start today with stevie from
asheville stevie from asheville you were
on the air
what's going on hey david how are you
doing today i'm doing well thank you
no thank you yeah it's funny i woke up
like 15 minutes ago
and i'm still waking up but i saw you
were doing this and i'm
well hopefully awake enough to have a
coherent question
yes yes sir all right so my question for
you
is what do you make of all this pipeline
issues that's happening i i live in
you know asheville north carolina and
we're seeing long
lines at the gas stations there's hardly
gas anywhere yeah
when is this going to end david from
what i'm reading
this is going to be resolved possibly by
the end of this weekend
i mean i don't know that i have any more
up-to-date information than you have
okay well how do you think joe biden and
his administration are going to
uh respond to this i've heard that
there's uh i guess
there's i don't know if it's a
conspiracy or if it's confirmed that
this was from russia
i have not heard that uh what i have
heard was that it is related to
um the method of attack was cyber
but i and i may just be behind on the
issue i've not even heard it asserted
that it was russia so i would want to
look into
that uh but i think that the biden
administration response will depend on
what we ultimately know about it i just
don't know
if that's definitive and i think i want
to be careful about speculating
of course of course are you going out
and like
filling bags with gas like we've seen
some people do
no no i i i thankfully i
i happen to get gas on sunday before
this all happened
so i'm i'm doing well but yeah i know
people are panic um filling up gas i saw
i did see someone i work for a company
where you know we're delivery and we i
saw people filling up canisters
three four five at a time yeah it's
actually ridiculous
i saw one video of a woman filling up a
plastic bag with gas and it's like once
you get it into the car what do you like
when you're holding the bag in the air
that could work
but then how do you set it down it just
didn't really make any
from the standpoint of um of mechanical
physics i wasn't understanding it yeah
yeah i mean maybe she's
come up with some sort of you know
metaphysical strategy that we're just
not
understanding like mere mortals like us
there was something there that made me
think i may not understand the
principles of solids gases
and liquids yeah i mean yeah
she could just be on a different plane
of existence you know like
i i don't know david all right well st
how's vaccination going down there
oh good you know i live in asheville
which is kind of you know it's uh
kind of a jewel in the midst of the
south yeah i'm personally vaccinated
myself
beautiful uh both um yeah yeah so it's
going good on my end uh my friends are
getting vaccinated i
apparently the uh numbers are going down
though
and uh for this for the country and i'm
a little nervous about that
yeah they're going they did but they are
actually taking back up now and with 12
to 15 year olds able to get pfizer i
think
i think we're on the up and up i really
think we're going to be looking pretty
good by memorial day
well david starting off my day that's
wonderful news because i've been
ignoring it
pleasure pleasure i got a little a
little scared a little nervous but
you know all right my friend i
appreciate the calls uh thank you
thank you david take care all right so a
big issue
gasoline still necessary for so much of
our daily lives
let's try carl from california
carl from california you were on the air
hello yup what's up how are you
uh well i was wondering uh how is the
um coping numbers planning i'm going
down it's like a specific date
event that um
[Music]
you know the code numbers are supposed
to like
calm down are they going down i don't
really know too much about this
they are going down yes so cases are
down about 85 percent from the peak
and declining deaths are down about 82
percent from the peak and declining
yeah okay that's good um i was just
wondering um
is donald trump planning on uh going to
a re-election and what do you think he
do you think he can make it i don't
think we will know until we see the 2022
results and what i mean by that carl is
donald trump wants to be the king maker
in 2022 he wants to decide
who are the good republicans and who are
the bad republicans and who gets
reelected and
because of the decision made about did
you see what happened with liz cheney
earlier this week liz cheney
the republican congresswoman was
stripped of her leadership role by
republicans i don't know if you heard
about that
yeah um sorry here's one more thing
uh oh i haven't even answered the
question yet carl but we can move on it
sounds like you have a big agenda to get
to
yeah sorry this is something that i was
actually uh
came here for oh okay so you had a video
and it said bite in hits uh 63
approval right 63 of approval yes
and one of my friends said that was like
um not correct like it was
done the polls were like specifically
biased for the democratic
party how were they buying
um one second okay
take your time carl please yeah i'm
sorry
oof are you are you lifting weights
uh yeah you are okay all right all right
carl thank you for the call we'll see
you
um i mean it's just it's off the rails
guys that we'll publish that because
it's funny but that don't don't be carl
don't be carl let's go next to
alejandro from san antonio texas you're
on the air
oh hello hello hello hello
awesome david um it's been about like
two years since
last time i called wow when i come back
thank you i'm so glad to have you back
so about that you're continuing to do
your show um
i the show has not yet the show has not
yet failed and collapsed
much to the the chagrin of many in the
audience
definitely yeah yeah one day guys just
you wait it will come
right um my question today for you
is is the world going to get a little
bit more
worse like more worse off like
politically not would covet
necessarily with everything going on in
the east middle east
you're saying is the world going to be
worse off for a while
yeah like i'm not talking about because
right now the focus is
on america with biden being the
president
trump gone like uh the dredge of it
lingering still but really everything
going on
globally seems very terrifying
you know it's kind of it's kind of like
we're sheltered in a way
there's no question about that um i uh
the the problem is that there are so
many different issues
uh background issues and acute issues uh
there are people who would hear your
question and they would say you know
the geopolitics really doesn't matter if
we don't deal with climate if we don't
deal with climate in 10
15 20 25 years we're screwed right that
would be a very macro
perspective uh someone else might say
you know the real issue
is this push towards right wing
nationalism
in the united states and in europe and
to some degree
even in latin america that someone would
focus on that it's such
an on a planet of seven to what are we
close to eight billion people now
would so many macro and micro problems
to deal with
foreign policy the pandemic i don't know
i mean you know the the stephen pinker
approach which has been much criticized
is a very long term macro view which is
the percentage of people embroiled in a
war is down
life expectancy is up infant mortality
is down terrorism is down violent crime
is down the number of people living in
abject poverty is down that's the
stephen pinker approach
there's a ton of people who are very
critical of that because they say well
stephen pinker is considering
circumstances today
in the same context the circumstances
200 years ago
we are so much more advanced right now
that our standards
should not be to compare how things are
today to 200 years ago does that make
sense
yes so it's very much perspective and
philosophy based but
taking all of that into consideration
for me
i think that the geopolitical issues
won't be resolved any time soon the
macro geopolitical issues
but that hopefully we have competent
enough governments to keep them at a low
enough level
that technological progress can continue
that
biomedical research progress can
continue and that we
deal with the climate issue um so i i
would put myself at like a cautious
optimism like 51 to 49
i don't know it's a small margin thank
you yeah
my pleasure thank you for the call it's
a good question i mean it's a big
picture question but
sometimes digging into the big picture
is a good thing
why don't we go next wow there are a lot
of people
hoping to get on today let's go next to
toby from
kansas toby you're on the air
hello yeah you're on the air toby hi
david um
i just had a quick question about if you
had any thoughts of
what was going on in the uk elections
last week
no i have not been following it no you
tell me what's been going on
um well it seems like kirsten has kind
of
ruined the outlook for labor for the
next
couple years what what happened
um well he didn't really have a concrete
manifesto
played out oh sorry i'm i'm losing my
uber right now sorry
you're losing your uber
oh my goodness they left okay wow
what a what a day just a lot of people
very very much embroiled in different
things why don't we go next to
um let's go to marshall from new jersey
marshall you're on the air hi
david can you hear me i can hear you
hey david i just had a pretty simple
question about uh
in a presidential election scenario in
which we
in which we see another split between
the uh electoral college result
and the uh popular vote result yes could
something like that
trigger enough of a backlash so that we
see
a uh speeded up um abolishing
the electoral college no and you know
the reason i say that
marshall is uh we had that situation
in the year 2000 and nothing changed and
then we had that situation again
in uh now my friend so obviously we had
it in 2016.
did we have it in between like in 2004
did carrie get more votes now i don't
remember
anyway the point sorry what was that i
think bush
i think bush won both popular and
electoral you know
in o4 okay yeah the the the point is uh
no
it's been 20 years this has been going
on and it doesn't see
listen what for the for as long as one
party benefits
from the system we have and republicans
benefit right now from that
uh they will resist changing it so no
i'm not optimistic that if it
it just one more time is going to make
it change nope
i don't see it and i still continue to
think that the best path
to effectively eliminating the electoral
college
is the national popular vote interstate
compact where you don't do it via
some change to the constitution just
enough states agree
to give their electors to whoever wins
the popular vote i still see that as the
most direct path
all right david i thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure marshall from
new jersey great to hear from you
i'm going to take a quick break but
don't hang up if you want to talk to me
because i'm going right back to the
phones in a moment
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
alright let's hear from a few more
people via discord you can go to
davidpakman.com
discord join the discussion 12 or 13 000
of you have done that i'm selling you
nothing
other than a free good time on the
discord
let's talk to oh this is interesting
it's someone from my native buenos aires
who goes by the name
b is that that's all you want to tell us
just the letter b
hi can you hear me david can you hear me
yes i can
awesome hi yeah i'm from buenos aires as
well
um so actually actually i
also share a jewish background like you
though i never moved to the states i
thought that was
interesting to mention beautiful um
yeah so what i see a lot is that
um it's very easy for someone like
menship here to claim to be
objective and do something that is
relatively um that i mean making
objective statements about problems he
sees in the left
and then completely fail to mention
anything that goes on
uh in the right that could be
problematic
and i think that's one of the main
issues why it's so hard for me to
be don't you think that also happens
with the left
leg we we can be pretty good at
complaining about
things that are just objectively uh
wrong in the
in the right but then failed to
uh complain about some of the things
that the left us that just
doesn't make a lot of sense yeah this is
a this is a basic
cognitive bias that people have um and
that includes
uh failing to see your blind spots while
being very
uh easily able to point out those of the
other side or your political adversaries
or whatever the case may be
uh confirmation bias looking for
confirmation for your pre-existing
beliefs rather than
fairly evaluating them i i think
absolutely that's uh that's a cognitive
bias and step one
in fighting against it is being aware of
it that's just you if you're not aware
of it
you're not going to have a good shot at
dealing with that and facing that
yeah i agree ma though um since you
agree with this part of the
question um don't you feel like
at times uh your channel and i'm not
saying that the
information that you provide is not
valuable because i do think it is very
valuable
don't you feel like sometimes you could
uh point out some things that
left us more precisely i feel like if i
have to
find out about something that the left
does that i really don't like i
have to find out about that from a right
leaning channel
and not i think that that i mean listen
i don't do as well as as i could right
there's more to aspire to
but i have made an effort to point out
when i think the left is failing to
actually
uh uh deal with issues correctly or
sometimes even failing to be
progressive and there are instances
where while i generally agree with the
left on tax policy
there are sometimes just economic
misunderstandings that groupthink takes
over and something gets popular on the
left and it's like when you think about
it it's not really great economic policy
or sometimes the left will go too far on
issues relating to
uh you know authoritarianism over
language or whatever the case may be i
mean
if the critique is i don't do it enough
or well enough
yes i welcome that critique um i will
say
i'm aware of it and i make an effort to
say hey
here's an issue on which the right is 90
wrong but the left
is 20 wrong and here's that 20 percent
and let's understand it and let's deal
with it
well i i definitely appreciate uh
um acknowledging the feedback it means a
lot to me
and yeah i i was also wondering given
that i lived so far
away from where you are and i i am
basically a different audience that
and your mainstream audience i was
wondering if you actually had any
questions for someone like me
you know i really don't other than what
part of buenos aires do you live
in
oh okay i have cousins there beautiful
area
yeah it's pretty cool well thanks all
for having me okay thank you
appreciate it we're on a slight delay
but i really appreciate the call
and uh hope to hear from you again all
right there's b
from buenos aires argentina a very
exciting phone call
let's go next to um
why don't we go to victor from indiana
you're on the air hi david so i was
wondering
how married are you to the idea of a
social democracy or having a social
welfare programs
under the framework of capitalism do you
think social i'm i'm married
i'm i i'm married to it but i have a
prenup and an annulment clause
so i could get out if it got ugly i see
got it no i mean sorry i i cut you off
so you're saying
i it sounded like you were saying how
married am i to social democracy
rather than socialism uh
sort of i guess my main question was do
you think
socialism or even something like
communism is feasible for a human
society
like maybe like a couple hundred maybe
even like i don't know like a thousand
years down the line
or do you just think that like
capitalism is pretty much the best we
got right now it's not worth talking
about
okay so here's where i'm different from
many other
commentators on this issue lots of
commentators you would go to them and
you would ask that question
and some people would say communism
is an inevitability it's just a matter
of when
and there are others on the right and by
the way you've got a horrible horrible
hiss coming through and if we could deal
with that
it would it would be a really great
thing
yeah um then you've got people on the
right
including trump i mean trump said it
during his state of the unions
that states of the union addresses
whatever
trump said we will never be a socialist
country i am not
going to pretend to tell you that
something definitely could or couldn't
happen
a thousand years down the line if you
asked anybody in the united states
there was no united states a thousand
years ago if you asked people a thousand
years ago
in 2021 would there be something like
the united states would we have the
technology we have would we have the
culture we have
nobody would have predicted this a
thousand years ago and so
i have no idea i i don't i think that
right now
everything has led me to my current
beliefs
which as you state fall under the
umbrella of social democracy that's
where i am right now is it possible that
things will happen in the next 200 or
thousand years where in a thousand years
uh the the plant planet earth is a
socialist
planet is a communist planet or there
are many communist countries
that that are flourish yeah it's how
could i say no how could i so
i just think that we are so bad at
predicting the future that it's
certainly possible
uh and if that happens i i don't know
what the path to it would be
that's a fantastic answer thank you so
much david all right my pleasure great
having you on and uh that's
that's an ugly hiss there that was
happening i'm glad we were able to get
it at least briefly dealt with
let's go next to um
why don't we go to max from illinois
max from illinois you're on the air hi
david
hello thanks for having me on pleasure
um i called you in or i called in to you
about
a year-ish ago um but
just to briefly sum it up i pretty much
was having an issue with my family where
uh they were all convinced that joe
biden was the only person who could win
in 2020 i suppose they were
correct in some sense i remember the
call i remember talking to you about
this
so i find myself in a new position now
where anytime i even
mildly critique biden yeah uh they call
me a trumpus
and assume that i'm coming at it from a
right-wing perspective right even as i
try to explain my left-wing perspective
yeah that's you know i've dealt with
this a little bit during my
you know during the trump era i would
cover the press briefings of kaylee
mcinanni or mckennany or marganani as
some of them call her
and i would just give my thoughts in
real time and
similarly now under biden i will cover
the gensake press briefings
and of course gen saki is not a liar
like kaylee mcinanni was
the uh substance the level of substance
is up
dramatically with gensake relative to
kaylee mcinanni you know it's
it's like a 90-10 it's a huge difference
but sometimes jen saki will like not
really answer a question or she'll say
something that doesn't make sense like
for example
the biden tax plan will not increase
taxes
on individuals nor on families earning
under 400 000 and someone will ask well
hold on is it is the
is it on individuals or or families
because usually for families it's twice
the end of
and she says it's both and it's like
that doesn't make any sense and i'll
point that out
and i'll get emails from people saying
how dare you
how dare you criticize jen saki she's
great
and it's like guys you know nope none of
these people are infallible and just
because we point out that something
doesn't make sense doesn't mean that
we're on the right all of a sudden
yeah um and that's kind of the argument
i've tried to make
though i i met with a lot of resistance
yeah
i don't know what to do to deal with
that because it's like do you have to
clarify every time
just to be i you know it's like in
family are you do you have to say
i support joe biden over trump and
thought trump was despicable
but when joe biden said x i don't think
that that was accurate like that's a
crazy way to have to communicate
especially with family
i agree though that's what i'm doing
currently oh it is that's how you do it
you frame it that way
i pretty much have to um and you know
they
they're a little bit more responsive you
know at least when i tell them i did
vote for biden but
it's it's a lot of the same of oh no
biden's basically infallible
yeah if you find some way to better uh
grease this
the wheels on those conversations let me
know
sure thanks david all right my pleasure
great to hear from you yeah that's
that's uh that's a sad
set of uh circumstances that's for sure
um
okay why don't we go to john paul jones
now john paul jones i remember we've
spoken before
because you didn't know that the led
zeppelin bassist was john paul jones
last time you were on right
um hey david um thanks for having me on
um
yeah i just wanted to say a few a couple
couple of things first of all first of
all i just want to say
say thank you for talking me out of
considering in
voting for third party last summer that
wasn't the main reason why
i backed away from voting from third
party but that was kind of
the thing that puts me over diaz like no
i'm not going to do that so
i just wanted to say thank you for that
thank you and then awesome
um also also i just wanted to say i'm
actually
start i'm in the process of starting a
new progressive
blog right now for my self and i just
was wondering if you and my other
progressive iconic kyle quinsky with
this y2 read
the first draft of my first blog article
on the battle week
sure send it to me through my website i
will take a look at it
um okay do you know how to contact kyle
too i've been trying to get in contact
with him but i just haven't been able to
i do not it would not be appropriate for
me to to
to do that
okay well okay um
so how would i send it for your website
uh
you go to the contact page on my website
okay okay thanks i'll just send i'll
it'll be it will be about about a week
or so before my
before before i put on my put in my blog
maybe
two so i'll just send it to you and
maybe you can read it
perfect all right very nice that's a
plan okay and uh
i just wanted to say i just wanted to
say oh thank you oh
thank you again again because i wasn't i
remember listening to that call
after it was uploaded to youtube but i
meant remember thinking man i was such
an
idiot oh my goodness okay we're going to
bleep that but i appreciate the call all
right john paul jones
uh very very strong i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry for cursing
great to hear from you okay my pleasure
he's shot out of a cannon today that is
really something else
okay let's see if we can just check in
um
with with a couple more people right i
mean there there's just so much action
happening right now
let's speak to brian from florida brian
you're on the air brian with a why
importantly can you hear me yes i can
right cool thank you and uh yeah brian
with the y
is very important uh uh big fan of your
show
i just have a question uh like uh
why so um why are you still covering
trump
sorry why am i still covering trump
yeah i mean he's not the president
anymore i get that he has a
a uh a base but uh yeah i mean so listen
i mean i've
i have a clip out about this already
we're really mostly not covering trump i
think this week out of about 50 stories
we do
i think like two or three are trump
related
um so we're really not but it you know
we to pretend that the
the republican party is no longer
trumpian would be delusional i would be
doing
you a disservice they just voted to
expel this cheney
it's uh you know this is a trumpian
republican party so to some degree i
have to keep covering it yeah
for sure but um there are
tons of stuff going on right now there's
some good stuff going on well that's why
again out of 50 stories this week i
think two or three had to do with trump
cool okay well maybe i just um i i watch
it
you know uh fairly regularly whenever i
whenever i can i just put it that way
yeah and i still still a huge you know a
big fan of your uh
of your of your channel i just think
it's not just you
you know what i'm saying and i you know
you haven't been highlighting it but a
lot of
um left-wing i guess you could label it
as that
uh they still talk about trump and um
the the minute he got uh the minute joe
biden got inaugurated
it was such a big uh relief and i'm you
know not to get into that but it just
seemed like
people would just fall back on on trump
and i still hear a lot of
um a lot of left people still talk about
him
yeah i mean again i think it's
appropriate because until the
the the republican party still seems to
be the party of trump
and if that's the case it's it's hard
not to talk about him uh
to some degree but uh i agree with you
that you know making
making it or anything the sole focus uh
when so many things are going on doesn't
make a lot of sense
even naming i mean it's labeled the
trump i mean it's just so many things
that gives power to his the the
like the entity of trump like it's a
trump base yeah
i don't know i i i should be rebranded i
don't know i mean it but the thing is
if it's if it's still the party of trump
if 70
of the party still thinks trump won if
two-thirds of the party would follow
trump if he left the republican party
it's not up to us to start calling it
something else when if and when the
republican party stops being the party
of trump i'll stop
saying it you know me me using different
language isn't actually going to change
anything it's just not going to
accurately reflect reality
i can't do that to my audience yeah for
sure
that's it man that's all right are we so
we're still we're still on good terms
right brian
oh yeah yeah okay good all right all
right
good thanks for the call i appreciate it
yep all right take care
uh there's brian from florida uh love
brian from florida great call
all right thank you to everybody that
called in there were always more calls
to take but at some point
it must end and we will take calls again
very soon
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
davidpakmanshow okay let's get into
audience questions for the week first
question one that came up indirectly a
lot of times
throughout stories we talked about this
week is there anything
at this point that convinced that would
convince trumpists that donald trump
actually lost
we are more than six months out there's
a so-called election audit
happening in arizona they're looking for
bamboo fibers
as evidence that the ballots were dumped
from china uh it's crazy what's going on
so the question is a different one now
six months out than it was six months
ago
six months ago we could have accurately
said um
after these various efforts failed to
demonstrate that there was
fraud as donald trump says some of these
trumpets will become uh convinced they
will accept that donald trump really did
lose and some did
the percentage of republicans that
believe trump won has declined
over the last couple of months but it's
still really really high
and at this point i don't believe
there is anything that would convince
these trumpets that donald trump
really just lost it wasn't stolen it
wasn't an illegitimate win by joe biden
or whatever the case
he just lost and there's two things that
are going on
number one at this point you know we
think of the holy grail of the maya
culpa which would be trump coming to
them and saying
sirs i lost that's it
even if he were to do that they still
wouldn't believe it they would say they
would do what's called the special
pleading they would say well
trump says he lost now but because he's
been forced
to say it the deep state or joe biden
threatened him with house arrest or
they got to him and it's not even you we
can't even believe donald trump when he
says this at this point in time that's
one possibility
now if you believe trump to be
the epitome of the alpha male the idea
that
he would be successfully blackmailed
by someone as weak as they see joe biden
being
that also doesn't make sense but
remember none of this makes sense so i
think
even if trump said i was wrong i lost
they those who still believe trump uh
actually won
would just say clearly somebody forced
trump to do that number two
we don't really even need to
theorize or speculate because
for a year trump said the virus isn't
serious
and we're winning and it's like the flu
and we don't need to worry about
anything
and it developed this huge anti-vaccine
sentiment on the right and then trump
was secretly
vaccinated in january at the white house
didn't tell anybody until he was asked
about it months later
and said yeah people people should get
it and
republicans are still the most
anti-covet vaccine group
out there it was too late after
feeding them the misinformation for
months and months really over a year
about the virus
by the time time trump simply said yeah
i got the vaccine and people should get
it
it was too late to even convince them so
once an idea has
spread virally in the minds of these
trumpists even
trump himself can't change their minds
that's how powerful these
uh viral memes of disinformation have
become
now last thing earlier in the week i
talked about anecdotal
thinking a lot of the
uh many of these trumpists believe biden
didn't really win he's not not
legitimate
and these types of things because of the
things that donald trump said
for so long but there are other
trumpists
who aren't able to get beyond anecdotal
thinking and what i mean by that is
even though we can go and say okay trump
got lots of vote votes but joe
so did joe biden and it was just record
turnout
and we understand why it makes sense
pandemic and one of the
biggest um sort of adjudications of a of
a
white house presidential term and who
knows how long
makes sense there would be a lot of
votes for a lot of these people it's
just anecdotal thinking
like i live in wherever mississippi
everybody i know voted for trump i don't
know anybody who voted for joe biden now
maybe you do but they're scared to
mention it because you're nuts
and they worry how you would react but i
don't know
the people around me and my deeply
conservative enclave all
um all voted for trump and
i went to a trump rally and it was
filled with trump people and
i watched fox news and they went to a
diner and everybody at the diner seemed
to like trump
my anecdotal thinking is uh informing
and superseding my views uh superseding
the the empirical broad strokes views of
polling and the fact that you don't hear
from most people on twitter you know no
no one place is going to tell you
sort of what the sentiment is of a
country with 331 million people so
that's another piece of it
and then there's people who are just
every combination of the above or bad
faith actors or
just suffering from a cognitive issue so
no sadly at this point in time
if you still believe that donald trump
actually won i don't believe there's
anything left that could convince you
other than just time over time maybe
some of these people will be
able to re-examine their beliefs about
the 2020 election
with some distance and objectivity
but beyond that i don't have high hopes
that we're going to convince these
people
nor do i think that we should be
employing a retail strategy
of arguing with individuals to try to do
it i think the way to win elections is
let's get turnout up let's prevent voter
suppression rather than arguing with
individual trumpists
hey david do you think mitch mcconnell
and republicans will be punished
for openly obstructing everything joe
biden does
as mitch mcconnell has promised to do i
wish i could tell you yes
the truth is mitch mcconnell might be
rewarded for obstructing everything that
joe biden tries to do
there have been no political
consequences
for mitch mcconnell and the republicans
of 2016
for blocking the merrick garland supreme
court nomination made by barack obama
and not only that
many republicans absolutely freaking
love it so
um we i mean listen the framing of the
question is correct
in that mitch mcconnell has said he's
not going to compromise
mitch mcconnell has said he's not
republicans aren't going to vote for
anything that joe biden wants to do we
saw it with covet stimulus democrats had
to go it completely alone
it looks like it's going to be that way
with infrastructure
these republicans want nothing to do
with the cove the the jobs bill
and on and on and on now there's a
couple of different ways that it could
go
one is these things are popular coveted
stimulus was popular
infrastructure is popular if republican
voters see
that hey we got this stuff and we like
this stuff but not a single republican
voted for it
they may say let's punish these
republicans in the fall
because if it were up to them we would
have gotten nothing at the same time
others would say hey you know what
what i still got the stuff and i don't
even have to vote for democrats so i'll
just keep voting for republicans that's
actually a rationalization we may see
among many of these republican voters i
think the biggest risk
to mitch mcconnell and republicans in
their obstructionism
is that a couple of republican senators
could be mitt romney could be you know
the same people that perennially
disappoint us
lisa murkowski susan collins if a couple
of them
say uh these are simple
uh needed things that joe biden wants to
do
i'm going to join the democrats um
assuming democrats have all 50 of theirs
including joe manchin and kirsten cinema
and get a couple republicans
that could start to hurt mitch mcconnell
where
you start seeing republicans abandoning
mitch
and saying now a lot of this stuff just
makes sense to do we need to do the
infrastructure i like the jobs bill
etc that's the biggest risk but
republicans if they remain unified
can withhold any
appearance of bipartisanship in order to
try to harm joe biden and democrats
and it could actually work there's this
you know
bipartisanship in a vacuum polls well
with voters
and so while my view of bipartisanship
is the president should do things that
the american people want if 70 percent
of americans want coveted relief
it doesn't really matter if you don't
have enough senate votes
you should do covet relief that
definition of bipartisanship is very
favorable to joe biden
the counter is that there are some
americans and again i
i think that people just working jobs
and feeding their families
they don't care about this stuff but
there are people who do
believe that bipartisanship means you've
got to have
some republicans voting for what you're
doing and if republicans can remain
unified
there might be enough of those people in
the republican party who would say joe
biden did it but he didn't do it the
right way
with covet cash it's not a factor i've
not heard anyone say
i got my 1400 bucks but i don't want it
because
you know mitch mcconnell didn't vote for
it come on guys give me a break
but with some of these other bills that
could become a factor so we're going to
see
the question of whether mitch mcconnell
will be punished
for the open obstruction is a good one
the question of whether mitch mcconnell
will be rewarded for the
open obstruction is just as good of a
question
david i've noticed that the term
gaslighting now
seems to be used too much has it become
problematic or even
meaningless yeah this is this is a good
question
um i this what's going on with the term
gaslighting is similar to what went on
with regressive left a few years ago and
i'll explain what i mean by that
gaslighting is when you manipulate
someone um
to get them to question their own sanity
or whether they can even trust
just the most basic facts they thought
they believed it's sort of like
uh you know you at a very mundane level
you ask your significant other um
never to wear shoes in the house 50
times
and then they wear shoes in the house
and then they you say uh
you know i we've talked about this so
many times and they say
we have and talked about it when when
was that i don't remember
right just like wait did we did i
imagine the 50 conversations just a
mundane example
um but uh it can happen uh
when with a whole bunch of other issues
political social cultural et cetera
there we are seeing something happen
with the term gaslighting that's similar
to
regressive left there was a very very
short period
and we talked about this in a long form
piece about the regressive left
where the term regressive left really
meant
someone who is ostensibly on the left
but who is failing to really do it for
example
sometimes a self-described leftist will
support
very authoritarian policy or
authoritarian elected officials or
world leaders and we would say this is
this is regressive left
in the sense that they claim to be left
but they're really just authoritarian
okay yeah that it had some kind of
meaning there um
it became a catch-all for
people who we disagree with and it was
used by the right
and by the left and it became
essentially meaningless
i stopped using it i used it very very
briefly to describe a very specific
thing
um racism is another one where there's
this trend
that we're starting to see where someone
will identify
something they believe is racist
they will be called racist for noticing
it sometimes you will hear this from the
right well they will say
you noticing race so much is a sign
that you are the racist and a very
similar dynamic is happening now with
gas lighting if you
say something is gas lighting you will
sometimes be called a gaslighter you
will say
you're gaslighting people by claiming
that gas lighting is taking place you
are manipulating your
virtue signaling by using that term
and a very very similar kind of vicious
circle
starts and it does devalue the term in a
significant way so i
i think there is still value you know
regressive left is now in the trash as a
term
i still think that gaslighting has value
and there is still
real objective empirical meaning that is
useful to us in describing
uh you know there was a lot of
gaslighting by the trumpian right
about just telling people what your
trump said what you were seeing and
hearing you cannot believe
that's a form of gaslighting um and i
think it still has value but they're
making every effort to devalue it
calling it
calling uh the use of the term an actual
gaslight in and of itself and all of
these terms have a shelf life that's the
that's the reality
so let me know your experiences with the
term either using it or having it used
on you or having it used
merely to muddle up conversations we
have a great bonus show for you today
it arguably is the best bonus show in
the last 24 hours from what i've heard
from pat
it's a very good one get instant access
by becoming a member at joinpacman.com
or
get on my newsletter because monday
memorial day
we are doing a one day membership
special we are just
blowing memberships out of here we're
going to just be dumping
huge amounts of memberships at a really
low rate uh it's going to be like a cash
cow it's a lost leader as the retail
giants would say
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com and then you will be
notified on memorial day
you'll know how to get this membership
special it'll be a beautiful thing
and before you know it you'll be joining
us on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman